في أكتوبر بعد وقت قصير من وفاة جمال ،
دعاك الرئيس ترامب إلى البيت الأبيض
وقلت إذا قدم مساهمة حقيقية
في الجهود المبذولة للكشف
عما حدث داخل القنصلية السعودية
في اسطنبول في ذلك اليوم ،
فسأفكر في قبول دعوته ، فقد رفضتها ، فهل
تفعل ذلك؟  أعتقد أنه سيكون
شيئًا جيدًا لك أن تذهب وتلتقي
برئيس الولايات المتحدة وتعرض
عليه قضيتك القوية جدًا
شخصيًا ، نعم هذا سؤال جيد جدًا
أود أن أشكرك على هذا
السؤال ،
جدد دعوته.  أنا في الولايات
المتحدة ، تم إرسال رسالة إلى
البيت الأبيض تفيد بأنني
قبلت الدعوة لذلك أنا
مستعد وأعتقد أنني قد أكون قادرًا على
قول أشياء أو اتخاذ خطوات غير المدرسة
لمقابلة الرئيس بنفسه مثل
مقابلته  أود أن أخبره
بحالة علاقتي الآن التي أشعر بأنني
مستعد للقائها ، لذلك أنا هنا اتخذ هذه
الخطوات وأواصل حياتي لاحقًا
في